I actually pushed myself to feel good
but when I really realized I wasn't good
because when I was warming up in the
morning for the ShakeOut when I was
starting like the power was there but
when I was kicking I was feeling out of
balance yeah and normally at that day
I'm Bruce Lee I'm whipping kicks
coming on my brain Confidence from it
yeah and then I I kind of like look at
gosh I'm like I'm looking at balance
today and he said like don't worry about
it don't even think about it it's like
cool because what is the worst what
happened you just gotta fight your ass
off yeah and I did that
I pressure the whole fight you kept on
board I I don't have a bruise after the
fight no yeah I wasn't even limping it's
crazy I think humble was limping a
little bit but